let's say we need to figure out how many
times 16 goes into 1388 and what I want
to do is first think about how we
traditionally solve a problem like this
and then introduce another method that
allows for a little bit more
approximation so traditionally you would
say well 16 does not go into 1 any time
so then you move over one spot well how
many times does it go into 13 well it
still does not go into 13 and then you
go all the way to 138 you say well 16
does go into 138 you say how many times
will it go into 138 and you might try 9
first and I'll do all my arithmetic here
on the right side so you'll say 16 times
9 6 times 6 times 9 is 6 times 9 is 54 6
times 9 is 54 1 times 9 is 9 plus 5 is
14 so it goes 144 times so that's still
that's still too big that's larger than
138 so it's going to go into it 8 times
8 times will be less than 138 so you
would stick an 8 here notice I have to
do this little trial and error here I
have to make sure I got the right exact
number I have to make sure I have put an
8 right over here then you say 8 times 6
is 48 and then 8 times 1 is 8 plus 4 is
12 so 8 times 16 is 128 so when I
subtract I get the remainder from 138 so
I get a remainder of 8 minus a to 0 3
minus 2 is 1 and then these cancel out
so a remainder of 10 but I still have
this 8 right over here so I bring that
down so I have 108 and then I do the
same thing again let me get rid of this
one we don't get distracted we say how
many times the 16 go into 108 and you
can approximate you say well it's
definitely not 8 times 8 times 128 is it
maybe seven times and then you might do
a little math on the side see 16 times 7
6 times 7 is 42 1 times 7 is 7 plus 4 is
12 or sorry plus 4 is 11 1 times yet 7
plus 4 is 11 so you 112 so that's still
too large so it's going to be 6 but
notice we have to do this little side
work on the side right over here to come
up to realize it wasn't 7 we now 6 is
going to be the largest how many
times you go into 108 without going over
it so 6 times 6 is 36 carry the 3 or
regroup the 3 depending on how you think
about it 6 times 1 is 6 plus 3 is 9 plus
6 is a plus 3 is 9 then you subtract
again 8 minus 6 is 2 and then you can
just say 10 minus 9 is 1 or you could
even borrow you can make this a 10 and
then that goes away 10 minus 9 is 1 so
then you have 12 and if we're not going
to decimals you're kind of done because
16 does not go into 12 so 16 goes into
1388 86 times with a remainder of 12
that right over here is your remainder
remainder and that's all all a decent
way of doing it and that's the way you
traditionally know how to do it but what
I do is introduce another maybe a little
more interesting way to solve a long
division problem so once again let's do
our 16 16 goes into 1388 and what we're
going to do is give us a much more
leeway for approximation or for
essentially guessing and what we want to
do is just guess we just we're going to
make guesses for how many times 16 goes
into the numbers without without
overestimating without jumping too high
and now we're not going to talk we're
not just going to think about the one or
the 13 or the 138 we're going to think
about the whole number as a whole and
before we do that I'm going to get two
things out of the way just because it'll
help us I'm just going to remind
ourselves what 16 times 2 and 16 times 5
are and I'm just picking these as random
numbers that we can use to approximate
you don't have to use 2 & 5 you can use
any numbers maybe I'll show other
examples there so 16 times 2 we know is
32 and 16 times 5 is 50 plus 30 is 80 so
let's just keep these these two results
in mind while we try to tackle this
right over here so the first thing to
think about is how many times is 16 just
our best guess our best guess for how
many times the 16 go into 1388 or
another way to think about how many
times does 16 go into a thousand let's
just let's just do something at a very
very rough approximation well we know so
we know it's not going to be 10 because
10 or it's not going to be 100 because
100 times 16 would be 1600
just throw those two zeros at the end of
it and you say how many times is go into
a thousand well we know 16 times 5 is 80
we know that 16 times 50 would be 816
times 50 would be 800 so let's use that
and I'm using I'm using the 5 I'm
multiplying it by another 10 to get 250
instead of the 2 because 800 is a lot
closer than 320 to our thousand that we
care about so what we could say is well
16 times 50 16 times 50 will get us to
800 will get us to 800 once again how
did I know that well 16 times 5 I've
know ahead of time is 80 so 16 times 50
I'm multiplied by 10 5 times 10 it'll
get us to 800 and then I just subtract
so I subtract here 8 minus 0 is 8 8
minus 0 is 8 and then you could say 13
minus 5 is 588 and now we ask ourselves
how many times the 16 go into 588 how
close can we get to that and let's just
assume that we only know this stuff
right over here or we could multiply 16
times a multiple of 10 so 800 once again
be too big
that gets us above 588 let's just go
with 320 right over here so we know that
16 times 2 we know that 16 times 2 is 32
so 16 times 20 16 times 20 is going to
be 320 I just multiplied the 2 times 10
which would give us our product times 10
and so we can subtract this right over
here 8 minus 0 is 8 8 minus 2 is 6 and
then 5 minus 3 is 2 so now I'm left with
268 and we say how many times does 16 go
into 268 and well let's see 800 is too
big even 320 is now too big well we
could say let's see 10 times 16 will
give us 100 60 let's just try that out
we don't even have to get the exact
right answer we don't have to get the
highest multiple that's less than 260 we
just have to make sure that we're still
within 268 so if we multiply let me do a
new color over here if we multiply 16
times 10 we get 160 160 we subtract
again
so 8 minus 0 is 8 6 minus 6 is 0 2 minus
1 is 1 and then we're left with well how
many times does 16 go into 108 and we
can go back to our we know 16 times 5 is
80 so let's just try out 5 so let's just
try 5 16 times 5 is 80 we subtract right
over here 8 minus 0 is 8 10 minus 8 is 2
so we're left with 28 and now it's
pretty simple how many times the 16 go
into 28 well it only goes into it one
time you only go into it one time and
then when you subtract 20 16 from 28 8
minus 6 is 2 2 minus 1 is 1 you're left
with a remainder of 12 but you might say
well how do we know how many times does
16 go into 13 88 or 1388 what goes 50 x
+ 20 x + 10 x + 5 x + 1 time so that's
going to be we could just add up all of
these things on the right hand side it's
going to be 50 plus 20 is 70 + 10 is 80
+ 5 is 80 5 plus 1 is 86 so there we
have it it went into it 86 times with
the remainder of 12 and what's cool
about this method is it at every step I
could have put a 60 over here and I
could have done the math correctly or I
could have done or I could have picked
my two multiples to be 16 times 6 and 16
times 3 and I would have gotten
different results here but at the end I
still would have gotten the right answer
so what it does is it gives us a method
so that we're always thinking about
we're always kind of biting away chunks
of what we're dividing into so first we
bit off an 800 piece chunk then we bit
off a 320 piece chunk and we keep going
until we until we essentially can't
divide by 16 anymore so hopefully you
found that kind of interesting